[Music]
the Disney Channel gave birth to some of
these biggest stars like Miley Cyrus
Demi Lovato and the Jonas Brothers now
it's time for the new generation we
decided to give them a new look stay
tuned to catch some of your favorite
actors looking like a cartoon character
don't forget to subscribe and give this
video a big thumbs up if you're a disney
fan now let's check out the ten Disney
Channel stars reimagined as cartoons del
Cameron you might remember dove Cameron
from Liv and Maddie where she did an
amazing job playing identical twin
sisters but did you know she also
portrayed the always cool mal in
descendants her looks are completely
different and if you didn't know the
actress you'd hardly believe that this
is the same person well we decided to
reimagine her as her own cartoon
character she might not have mouths
purple hair but we think she's still
pretty awesome check her out her blonde
hair would definitely fit a cartoon
characters look we also highlighted her
gorgeous eyes dug herself commented that
her eyes seemed to change color
sometimes they're brown sometimes
they're blue and sometimes green which
is exactly the eye color of her cartoon
character did you know that dove had to
wear an eyepatch in 2015 because she
gave herself a creeper cut on the eye
now that would be a very interesting
cartoon character what do you think
could she appear in a couple of famous
TV series we think she'd be an excellent
addition to the loud house or perhaps we
could just stick her in Maleficent since
she does actually play the daughter of
an iconic Disney villain we're also sure
she could easily get her own Disney
Princess story hey guys we are so
excited to announce we are producing our
own original content head over to the
trendy for the best DIYs fashion tips
makeup acts and so much more we are sure
you're going to love it
and be sure to let us know what you
think in the comment section we love to
hear from you Bella Thorne speaking of a
wild character Bella Thorne is
everyone's favorite wild child and she's
not stopping anytime soon at least we
hope she's not let us know if you love
Bella as much as we do we're obsessed
with her looks and officially jealous of
her hair the shake it up star rocked
many hairstyles over the years that our
favorite has to be the 2017 neon pink
hair her style is completely awesome and
we're pretty sure she'd perfectly fit in
the cartoon world check out what we
thought she looked like as a cartoon
character pink hair a septum piercing
glitter on her face and just tons of
different colors her eye makeup is just
stunning and absolutely perfect for a
cartoon character Bella would probably
be a sassy character with tons of
attitude did you know that Bella is best
friends with Drew Barrymore from
Charlie's Angels
she calls drew mala fickle and we think
we just found a perfect nickname for her
own cartoon character
she also said her lucky color is green
she'd fit in in a cartoon like Teen
Titans go and we even see her as one of
the Powerpuff Girls we're also pretty
sure that she'd play a perfect Disney
villain with her dark and colorful look
what do you think booboo Stewart if
you're not yet a fan of booboo Stewart
you're about to become one after this
video who doesn't like the charming guy
with piercing eyes from The Descendants
the talented actor actually received his
first record deal with Walt Disney
Records at the age of 12 we have to say
we have a soft spot for boo-boo whose
full name is actually Niels Alan Stewart
even his nickname is way too adorable
his eyes are definitely enchanting and
we've decided to really make them stand
out in our cartoon version check him out
there's his long dark hair and a hoop
earring in one ear doesn't he look cool
or what as an actor boo boo is sweet and
humble boo boo said he was really into
yo-yos as a child in fact he was so good
he said he could be called the yo-yo
master for that reason alone and of
course for his looks we think Boo Boo
would be a perfect addition to a cartoon
show like Edie Edie and Eddie or we
could always just pair him up with
Aladdin since Jafar is his character's
father after all hands up for boo boo if
he's your favorite Disney star
he's definitely ours
Selena Gomez is Selena your favorite we
bet you'll love our cartoon version we
can't forget about this pop sensation
who actually started her career as a
Disney Channel actress alongside stars
like Miley Cyrus Demi Lovato and the
Jonas Brothers
since then Selena who was actually named
by the late singing sensation selena
quintanilla made a huge name for herself
in the music industry she's also the
most followed person on instagram he
adore her gentle look and her cartoon
version was actually pretty easy to make
we decided to highlight her gorgeous
eyes and of course her beautiful lips
we also adore her gorgeous long brown
hair she looks like the perfect cartoon
character you could easily put her in
just about any cartoon there is but we
picked Bratz she could easily portray a
Bratz doll and could probably make the
character sing her heart out did you
know that Selena lives an Instagram free
life even though she's one of the most
followed accounts on the app she said
that it had become so consuming she
needed to go under the radar to clear
her head however we're pretty sure a
Bratz version of Selena would love to be
in the spotlight Cole Sprouse here's
another Disney favorite that practically
grew up right in front of our eyes you
probably know Cole Sprouse from The
Suite Life of Zack and Cody
which was one of his latest projects
before he took a five year acting break
we bet there's a lot of you that had a
crush on Cole
during his Disney Channel gig but we
have to tell you that he looks even
better in the Riverdale series we've
reimagined him as a cartoon character
and honestly we're still totally not
over Cole check him out his greenish
blue eyes are totally gorgeous and we
love his messy hair coaxial shared a lot
of wisdom when he opened up on his
five-year break from his acting career
and mentioned it's fundamental for child
actors since then he studied at NYU and
it looks like he's now refreshed and
ready to get things rolling we see Cole
in a cartoon like the loud house where
he'd probably enjoy annoying his ten
other siblings considering he had a lot
of practice with his twin brother Dylan
we'd actually love to see The Suite Life
of Zack & Cody cartoon did you have a
crush on Cole as a kid be honest
sky Jackson if you've watched our videos
on the behind the scenes of Jessi then
you probably know a few things about sky
Jackson no one would ever expect but
regardless of who she's feuding with we
still
love this pint-sized actress although
best known for her role in Jackie sky
also played the adorable Zuri and
Jessie's a spin-off called bunk she's
definitely an adorable character so why
not give her a cartoon makeover what do
you think we love Skye's hair but her
cartoon hair makes her look totally
awesome but it looks like her big brown
eyes stand out even more she'd be a
totally awesome character especially if
she'd have a personality that's anything
like Zuri Ross speaking of cartoon
characters did you know that Skye is
actually the voice of Issa in Dora the
Explorer and little fish on Bubble
Guppies she can definitely play a
cartoon character but we think she
deserves her own cartoon version instead
of playing an adorable animal her
character would be perfect in a cartoon
like The Simpsons just imagine another
sweet but sassy child on the show
she'd probably give Bart a run for his
money when it comes to mischief and we
bet she'd drive Lisa insane come on
let's make Jesse the cartoon happens
Sabrina carpenter here's another one of
our favorite Disney stars although she's
been singing covers on her YouTube
channel for what seems like forever
Sabrina officially became a Disney star
in 2014 after landing a role of Maya
Hart in the popular show Girl Meets
World that year she also released her
very first EP followed by two
full-length albums and she now appears
to be one of the most popular young
artists her fun personality makes her
stand out from the rest so naturally we
had to see what she looked like as a
cartoon character
here she is with long blonde hair and
gorgeous blue eyes doesn't she look
totally adorable her personality is
super sweet and she could easily portray
a modern version of Snow White she's got
the voice the gentle look and she's
definitely just as kind speaking of
Sabrina did you know that she doesn't
only act and sing she's trained in
ballet since she was two years old which
basically makes her a triple threat
we're telling you it's just a matter of
time because this talented actress takes
over the world and has Disney Channel
cartoons of her own Disney if you ever
need cartoon inspiration we already have
it covered
Sophia Carson we can't get enough of
descendants the movie introduced us to
so many talented Disney stars we
absolutely have to see what they look
like in a cartoon setting Sophia Carson
plays mouths best friend eazy-e B has a
cool duck look as does the actual
tres unlike other Disney stars Sofia's
breakthrough role with Evie in
descendants but we're sure there's more
in store for this talented actress check
out Sofia as a cartoon isn't she
gorgeous
we love her big eyes her long brown hair
and her red dress she looks totally
different than the blue haired character
she portrays on descendants if you could
see her nails they'd probably be dark
blue because Sofia keeps her nails dark
blue all year long no matter what outfit
but she's not only an actress Sofia is
also a super talented singer we think
she'd be absolutely perfect on an
adorable show like Little Einsteins
of course she could also play the
daughter of the Wicked Queen and Snow
White
because well that's what her character
actually is we can't wait to see more of
Sofia as we're sure she'll become a huge
star in the next few years
sindhya and you can forget about the
talented and totally gorgeous India we
can name at least nine celebrities that
are having a crush on the popular star
and if we're being honest we can't blame
them zendaya
whose name means to give things rose to
popularity after she appeared on shake
it off in 2010 since then she has been
turd into the celebrity world and become
a household name her flawless looks are
everything and we hope our cartoon
version gave her the Justice she
deserves what do you think we can't get
enough of those gorgeous brown eyes and
her always perfect hair the earrings are
a perfect add-on as is the off the
shoulder dress
speaking of some day--is hair did you
know that it's totally natural she said
she never dyed it and has had the same
hair color since she was born no wonder
it's so gorgeous so let's go back to
zendaya
as a cartoon we all know she slays
practically everything in everyone and
we love seeing her attitude come out on
Twitter so her cartoon character would
probably be completely sassy we feel
like she could easily join the Powerpuff
Girls and take the sassiness of
buttercups to a new level although her
name is so awesome and powerful she
could easily have her own show where
she'd be the main character be honest do
you have a crush on zan day out if you
do don't worry we can definitely relate
China and McClain weed that you can tell
by now that we're huge dissonance fans
and we can't deny it you probably know
China from playing the awesome villain
called uma and descendants too but the
truth is China was a Disney star long
before she landed this
she played Jasmine in house of pain and
Chyna parked an ant farm and she even
had a cameo in Hannah Montana she
definitely deserves her own cartoon
character and here it is of course we
have reimagined her as uma because
honestly who can forget her performances
in the movie her blue hair is totally
awesome as is her pirate hat along with
her entire outfit did you know that her
friends have a ton of bizarre nicknames
for China including tea tea and Thai tea
and we all know which cartoon she'd fit
in in fact she was already in a cartoon
version of dissonance called descendants
wicked world but she gave her voice to a
character called Freddie she definitely
deserves portray uma in a cartoon
version of descendants
although China herself said she loved to
transform into Beyonce I learned her
fierce choreography in fact the talented
McClain sisters could all have their own
cartoon show come on Disney let's make
it happen
Cameron Boyce who doesn't love Cameron
Boyce since we love both Jessie and
Simmons it's only fair we highlight the
Disney star that was in both of those
shows Cameron Boyce is very easy on the
eye but he's also extremely talented
absolutely hilarious and of course a fun
person to hang out with it's hard to not
love him on descendants but we promise
you'll also love his cartoon version
isn't he just adorable
we'd love his iconic white hair his wide
grin and of course the cute freckles
we're pretty sure Cameron could fit in
every cartoon but we actually see him in
a wacky show like Edie Edie and Eddie or
even something like Adventure Time he'd
fit right in with the rest of the
characters he did say that he loves
playing all the crazy characters he gets
to portray in gamers guide to pretty
much everything so he'd probably do just
fine in the show that makes no sense at
all and since his fairy tale characters
mother is of course Cruella De Vil a
cartoon version of Cameron would
actually be amazing in 101 Dalmatians
probably be the same jumpy character he
is in descendants do you have a favorite
Disney Channel laughter let us know in
the comments for more videos like this
one check out 10 descendants two
characters reimagined as cartoons see
you next time
[Music]